-Today is Friday, and that's
usually when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
And I was just running
a bit behind today,
so I thought if you guys
wouldn't mind, I would like to
write out my weekly
thank-you notes right now.
Is that cool with you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much.
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
It looks like he's got a secret
or something.
-Wow.
♪♪
-Thank you, Christmas stockings,
because the only thing better
than getting socks for Christmas
is getting them
inside an even bigger sock.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ah!
-Oh, yeah, a sock. How meta.
-A sock.
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, seeing my own breath
when it's cold,
for being the closest
I'll ever come
to doing vape tricks.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you,
tracking packages online,
for letting me know that UPS,
FedEx, and the post office
still have nothing
on Domino's Pizza Tracker.
That thing works.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Bing bong!
♪♪
-Thank you,
artificial Christmas trees,
or as the rest of the plants
in your house put it,
"Um, who is she?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, licking a candy cane
into a pointy edge,
for making me feel like
I'm in a North Pole prison.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Herbie!
-[ Chuckles ]
We're getting Herbie
out of here.
♪♪
Thank you,
holiday family newsletters,
for basically being
your aunt's way of saying,
"Here's all the stuff you would
have seen me post this year
if you hadn't muted me
on Facebook."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
-Oh.
Wow!
-7-point font.
-[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Thank you, paper snowflakes,
for turning document shredding
into a family activity.
[ Applause ]
"Let's take daddy's taxes,
make it into a snowflake."
[ Light laughter ]
-Snowflake.
♪♪
-Thank you, gingerbread man,
for somehow being okay
living in a house
that's made out of you.
There we have it, everybody.
Those are our thank-you notes.